[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're taking you down the river
we're gonna take you down the rapids
we're gonna lose some people off the
boat oh no and we're not gonna be able
to find them
maybe it's my friend from college or
maybe it's my friend from internet who
was also my friend from college you
consider me your friend from internet
first of all you didn't even say the
internet
um
i was kind of hoping you would be
wearing your willy nelson shirt that i
got you
um
you know i went to the palomino festival
yeah and every day you show up with a
new damn t-shirt i'm like how many
t-shirts did you buy at this festival
that i was also supposed to go to but i
was too coveted yeah to go to it so i
went pretty bitter without you every day
you show up with a t-shirt and it's like
rubbing it in my face let me say two
just take the t-shirt off and rub it in
my face no you don't want that number
one this is a shirt that i didn't i did
not get the shirt at palomino festival i
got this shirt while i was on my
vacation in santa barbara at a surf shop
because this is like a collab
shotgun between willie nelson and i
think pacsun
some brand
does it say it
bri brixton brixton that's different
than pacsun yeah they would brixton
would be sold at pacsun
but the t-shirt that i got you i saw
this awesome willie nelson t-shirt that
said willy's reserve and i was like oh
yeah that link will love that but that's
that's like where
he people go to like
shoot game right
no it's willie's weed brand i did not
know at the time that this is willie
nelson's cannabis company
willie's reserve so just be careful
where you wear it link be careful where
i wear it be careful where you wear it
probably shouldn't wear it on the
internet
i haven't worn it
matter of fact
have you even tried it on i usually
launder my shirts first
interesting i guess normal size people
can do that because you're
it's a i don't i wear a large t-shirt
but i i don't want it to fit
medium points this is funny because this
morning i put okay i saw this shirt
hanging up my wife had washed it we used
to have this agreement that you cannot
wash and dry
my t-shirts but that was back when
t-shirts were a little bit skinnier a
little bit tighter
and then i upgraded to the xl and i was
like oh excels basically well the style
has changed right so they've gotten a
little bit bigger
she washes she washed this and i have a
pretty good sense of just looking at a
shirt on a hanger and knowing if it's
gotten too short then i was like oh no
she she messed my shotgun willy shirt up
but i put it on and it actually fits
okay
because i before i put it on i was like
i'm not gonna have to start getting two
xl's and then laundering them and drying
them real hard
apparently not
shotgun wheel is a great song i think
it's also the name of the album sits
around in his underwear and it's um
i think it became one of his monikers
after after that uh song came out
yes
right
but that's not what we're talking about
today we're talking about we went back
to colorado
yeah we did we're just kind of doing
that we're you know what we're really
into the denver airport and all the
conspiracies around it i'm fine we want
to visit
the denver airport as much as possible
i'm not fond of the denver airport it's
rather large we're not going to really
get into there's a red-eyed bronco the
conspiracy theories but if you want to
if you're that kind of person
uh you know me i'm not into conspiracy
theories unless i'm doing a bit on gmm
there's tunnels um
there's all kinds of theories about this
thing it was built in 1995 i think it
cost three billion dollars more than the
the expected budget which is a lot of
money it took a lot of extra time
because they built a tunnel all the way
to fort collins so people are like
there's a tunnel that goes like a
hundred miles to colorado springs i
think is the theory uh there's like uh
the illuminati supposedly uses it the
most interesting thing is there there is
that big bronco that's out first of all
it's in the middle of nowhere outside of
denver just on the plains right yeah and
then there's this big giant blue bronco
of course
like the denver broncos it's their
mascot but this thing is massive and has
these lit up red eyes that
don't always
you don't it's like you have to drive
past it and at a certain angle boom it's
like the thing just kind of lights up
and looks directly at you it lights up
well it's they're all they're all i was
driving the rental car so i was able to
see the eyes and the thing is you know
what the name of the thing is lucifer
really yes and the artist this is freaky
only that statue or the mascot for the
football team i think only that statue
okay the artist
was killed
by the statue while he was building it
uh uh
how a piece of the horse fell off
and cut an artery in his leg and he bled
out no
no
i ain't making this stuff up man
wikipedia that somebody else is making
it up no no no no that's so there's a
lot of things there's all these weird
there's images around the airport and
there's people think that there's some
sort of nazi thing going on
i i think that all of that and and
interestingly the denver airport like
the ceo of the denver if you go on the
denver airport website the ceo of an
airport they have yeah it's a big job
they have decided to embrace not the
nazi part but the conspiracy theory
stuff because they were like we spent
some time trying to dispel these things
and now we just embrace it and it's just
part of the fun of the airport because
there's like gargoyles
around the baggage claim or something to
like ward off evil spirits but it's just
you know it's just like architectural
decisions or whatever
but that
bronco killed the artist
wow that's like the desk of gmm killing
one of us
man what happened on that
or the round table of dim lighting if
you had to be killed by the gmm desk or
the round table of dim lighting which it
was and you were gonna it was because an
artery was cut and you were going to
bleed out which one would you choose i
don't think they're around them
the gmm desk could probably cut you with
one of those corners it's dim in here
though you you might there's there's a
hazard with visibility that's true
so anyway we enjoy the denver airport
it's a beautiful airport other than the
conspiracies so
this this trip was a long time in the
works
just to give you a little background
when we on this podcast started we
released our lost years this is
pre-pandemic
like i mean
like weeks before the pandemic really
hit
in 2020 uh we released the last years
yeah a little hair that i feel like
needs to be addressed oh yeah
you got it did i address it yep
okay
um
and you know for those of you listening
it was not a pube our friends
we gave
you know our friends back home you know
they're they're
they're uh
their faith is
still intact now i'm not gonna speak for
them
friends back there only one of them
they're not back home but like our
friends from college that we
you know we were in and out of touch
with like we're still we're still
friends but we're not like
actively talking to them
all the time like active friends
pre-pandemic but at different points
when we were visiting back home at least
one friend like i gave him a heads up
gave harm a heads up that like hey we're
going to talk about our spiritual
deconstructions
on the podcast i'm
i'm approaching this with some
trepidation
and you know so i was able to have some
good conversation because
you know we experienced
uh
being involved in campus crusade and
like our college years and all that
stuff with them like these are our
closest friends so it's like giving them
a heads up kind of telling them it's
coming and um just the general response
was of
support you know and like hey you know
i'm your friend i'm i'm here for you
yeah i'm as as you go through this who
knows how this is gonna all come out
so that's when we that's when we started
like reengaging and kind of
upping the ante on our friendship i
think
right before the pandemic then when the
pandemic hit
well no before the pandemic hit as the
last year's podcast were coming out
we had i believe we had a video chat or
two where we were like
talking to them about it because they
were you know they said they wanted to
support us and it's one thing to say
that thoughts and prayers but it's
another thing to say hey
how are you doing i'm sending you a text
let's talk
and then like we're all getting on video
chats and talking then when the pandemic
hit
we were like it kind of shifted to being
about talking about our shared
experience in the pandemic because
you got harm in north carolina you got
greg who you met greg on this podcast
months ago
he's in washington state and uh tim was
in uh
st louis baltimore is what i was gonna
say st louis at the time he's in new
york state now
and uh another friend of japan
yes you know and so in this group we got
we got a guy who's like
heading a seminary we got a guy who's a
full-time pastor we got a guy who takes
pictures of
uh
real estate properties yes but is very
involved in this church
you know so like
that that's their that's where they're
coming from but we were we were such
good friends in college and then the
pandemic like really strengthened our
friendship and i remember early on it
was like man this is this is nice this
is a source of strength to be able to
connect with these people this is
something we talked about over
um over many podcasts and like
highlights of the year i think we
brought it up
so our friendship got re reignited who
knew the pandemic would last so long
we would do a video chat every week
every couple of weeks pretty much said
it
okay yeah fair point
if you go back and they've said we're 20
23 we're still gonna be thinking about
this but even early on
like the first six months of the
pandemic as we were like having these
video chats this idea started to
percolate of
when this is over
we we should all get together
we should do something we should like
because i think that it's and then we're
like let's not let's not all get
together in north carolina boring let's
have a let's have a trip but it's i
think it's important uh because i i
i do we're not this isn't the point of
the conversation is not to talk about
the fact that
we're in a different place
spiritually and the nature of our
friendship we're just going to talk
about the time that we had together but
i i do want to just
address that a little bit because
i don't know you know i tend to engage
more about this stuff than you do right
like
if somebody says something to me on the
internet about it or ask a question
i'll get into it i i i
enjoy kind of going back and forth with
people who disagree with me about things
um a little bit and so
you know and i kind of give off the vibe
that like i kind of still want to talk
about this i mean i'm releasing a damn
album that's all about my spiritual
deconstruction right i'm kind of yeah
i'm sort of in i'm on i'm in that camp
right
uh so i'm kind of inviting conversation
i'm inviting challenges and that kind of
thing
um and and i do think that people might
be like oh you guys have like sworn off
anything to do with church or
christianity or in and you me may think
that it impacts relationships and
friendships and i think it's really
interesting and not it depends on the
nature of the
the person right because there might be
people who are like
you have made these public statements
and you have established yourself in
this particular position and you're kind
of in opposition against evangelical
christianity from a philosophical
standpoint
um and therefore i can't have a
relationship with you there are people
who would take that stance but that's
not the stance that we've taken i'm
still in very close relationships with a
lot of people who are still very much
evangelical christians
um
and i think that
you know and i'm not going to speak for
these dudes because i think that they
can speak for themselves i think by the
way i i am too i i got my i got my
former church friends i got a i got a
few key ones yeah and uh you know all
i'm gonna say is that while we
definitely have disagreements about some
fundamental things it's like
the foundation of our friendship
is love
and that love is still intact and that
love surpasses
our disagreements and we can like we we
had a lot of really lively
you know discussions or whatever it's
not it's not argumentative and it's not
like it doesn't get heated i'm just it
is
we i think we all at least a certain set
of us in this group kind of enjoy
talking about these things and like
talking about things from a
philosophical spiritual standpoint or
whatever
and
it's just kind of a i think that these
guys
i think what i'm trying to say is these
guys are a great example of how
christians can interact with people who
have deconstructed yeah and you know
what
i i think i have some thoughts about it
but i want to come back to it in the in
like after going through the whole trip
because i think that kind of sheds light
and perspective
on on the thoughts that i have about it
in response to what you're saying okay
so like i think this is going in a good
place
i just maybe just i'll just put a pen in
it just kind of come back to that as
kind of a book end thing all right the
other way to look at this was i mean
i we just had this desire to get
together and do a trip because like we
were really en enjoying reconnecting and
yeah every kind we talk about the
pandemic so much we talk about our lives
it's not like we talk about
our spirituality constantly it's it's
it it moved into just being one of the
many things we would talk about
um
and then it so that the trip finally
happened you know we we said let's meet
in denver it could be a central airport
for people coming from all over the
place
and then
um
we can you know let's get an airbnb
where everybody can have their own
bedroom i really appreciate
i found you making that determination
that was a huge and it was not easy to
find when you got like five guys you
each need your own room big that's a big
house um going outside of denver uh we
were near idaho springs and we're like
what can we do around there white water
rafting baby
this is perfect this is a perfect like
mid-life
college boys
somehow still friends let's get back
together let's do something a little
death defying you know city slickers
haven't seen it but my understanding is
that like it's a midlife crisis you
haven't seen city slickers
i i would love to see it it's just you
know i'm i'm a i'm a busy man
we didn't talk about gme in the first
five minutes
we can talk about the stipulation waste
was that a stipulation or is it just a
twist it's an internal okay so so we're
going to say it so i'll say it right now
i say so i haven't yeah i haven't seen
sli slitty slickers
that's different that's porn
that's the porn i haven't seen that
either
oh speaking of which
slitty sick slickers slitty sick that
slit
slitty slickers sickers [ __ ] stickers
wow um good mythical evening is right
around the corner yes it is and um who
knows maybe maybe we should watch that
uh good transition we got a lot of stuff
planned get your ticket now for the live
event exclusively on moment house watch
it as it's happening
whatever happens you will see
yeah
it's gonna be r-rated there will be
drinking it's gonna be
it's gonna be full of surprises for us
and we might have some surprises for
you september 1st
mark your calendars clear your schedules
go to goodmythicalevening.com and grab
that ticket
um
so
yeah we made plans to go whitewater
rafting
and hang out at this airbnb and do some
other stuff and it i mean
it
it definitely felt like
that kind of midlife it was it like city
slickers
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um
probably
i think we are most likely uh
we're probably actually a little bit
older than the city slickers were
billy crystal clystel yeah
billy klistel is the porn version
billy
stop it i was trying to get it right hey
man you got to save some stuff for a
good mythical evening um i'm just
warming up okay uh but yeah so
the thing i was thinking was
the dad energy yeah that was kind of
permea permeating everything like when
you got when we all got into the
suv
to go somewhere and like you made the he
was like isn't it interesting to be here
and to not have to say something like
does everybody have all this the stuff
they need has everybody taking a leak if
you need to use the bathroom do you have
your phone
right when a bunch of dads get together
who are
who are the ones who are constantly
saying those things to their families
it's like everybody's just you have to
worry about anybody it was everybody
just got themselves figured out it was
so great and when we had to check out by
10 a.m everybody scrambling doing their
thing everybody's pitching in to like
take the trash out and put the sheets in
the right spot and the towels in the
right place and this that and the other
and we all get in the rental car
and i look at the clock
10 a.m on the dot baby yeah that would
be dad mode engaged if i was with my
family not a chance
and we would i definitely wouldn't have
a smile on myself confirms
i am not the problem i'm not either
because when left in my own devices
i get out of the place on time right
i'm not the problem i'm not saying my
beautiful
wife is the problem
it's probably the children
but it could be my wife as well i don't
know because i i haven't experimented in
that way to isolate her i don't know
so it'd be my beautiful wife's problem
it felt good
you know and and everybody
everybody was pretty pretty pretty laid
back
you know yeah i don't know oh i don't
know some of us are we got different
gradations of being laid back
but there's like
i was driving that made me feel good
i actually felt
like i'm driving if you had to rank i
picked the place the laid backness of of
the group
one to five yeah
um who's the most laid back and who's
the least late greg is the most laid
back
and then
next it may be
i don't i'm debating between tim
and you
i think it's you
um
it's definitely you
because there will be times when i was
driving and then all of a sudden tim
would be the one speaking up saying
uh we just passed the grocery store that
we were supposed to go to
and if you don't
but the town that we're going to is up
here and if you keep if you go to that
place first if we go to that liquor
store first and then come back to the
grocery store then it's going to add 40
minutes to our trip and i was like i did
not know that brilliant let's turn
around right so it takes a level of like
i'm actually you know i had a gps on and
then he's back in the back seat with
another one on just like
catching my errors which is great
and then i would rank
uh who's left
me
harm
oh this is this is uh
you're both enneagram ones yeah which
already
and and we're the ones
it's between the two of us is the reason
why the trip happened let's be real oh
yeah this is i think this is one of the
this is why
different personality profiles
which we kind of analyzed through the
grid of the enneagram but it just means
different personality
types
you you need some ones and you're it's
helpful to have some ones in your group
just to make sure that the things
everything goes perfectly planned
but then you need some
other
other people in your group
other non-ones in your group so that you
can actually have a good time
yep yeah yeah you can't you can't have
it all once you got to set it up and
then you gotta spike it i made a lot of
the plans and then but harm was the one
who would be like whenever we
found out it was tim's birthday and he
was like i want to eat a steak and then
you're like we're going to get you a
steak and then you kept throwing out
steak places and then harm would be like
that's too far
you know it's like he's got his he's got
his moments of asserting that like bad
idea
not doesn't fit within the parameters of
perfection which i appreciate you know i
i felt like i didn't have to be the one
to evaluate everything and because i was
kind of
the leader i was the leader
okay
i was the driver
and i knew the itinerary
i wasn't really the leader but i felt
like that there were checks and balances
between harm and tim i'm gonna put
i'm gonna i'm gonna put harm at number
one i'm gonna put me at number two okay
and then i'm sure i'm gonna hear from
him
later
uh
okay speaking as uh uh an innocent
bystander maybe we were tied um
yeah i you know i think my assessment is
that
while
harm is much more of a 1-1 than you are
a 1-1
right because okay
you are
incredibly disorganized and forgetful
and and like absent-minded in the way
that most ones don't like you lose your
keys you come to work
yesterday you came to work oh i left my
laptop at home you come to work you
usually don't have your id if we need to
go someplace and we and you need an idea
ah yes
but me being a one
only translates into then i just felt
like a failure
but harm is like he's com he's a very
buttoned up one yeah he wears more
buttons than me um
but so i it's interesting you have a
chaotic energy but you're also a one so
i think that when your oneness comes out
it can come out in sort of a
semi-aggressive nature in a way that
harms never comes out the only time that
my
that i got testy was when that last
morning when we were stalling to go to
the airport
we couldn't find anything worth doing
after visiting
red rocks amphitheater which was awesome
we had a few more hours
and then it was just like we we we got
on scooters in like downtown denver and
it was like that is not i was not
impressed well you made that very clear
i was not happy i was like you know what
next time
we're just gonna get up and we're gonna
get on the plane and get the hell out
like that's like that's the other thing
about
maybe it's a one thing too is that like
the whole time i was assessing
what are we learning here for next time
and i found out the only person i could
talk to that about was harm really but
there was that moment that was nice
there was that moment what are we gonna
do next year and the the next to last
day where i pointed out where i was like
you said something like you're like
something you said something about this
town that we're in i was like okay
in the past two hours you have
complained about yeah
this town this restaurant this walk that
we're on right now like you complain
about a lot of things and that was your
that was your what i call your
aggressive oneness should have never
have gone to aspen
i'm just saying i think that's what it
was so i'm what i'm saying ultimately
i'm not throwing you under the bus but
i'm putting you at number one because
while i think that harm is the most
one-on-one
in a lot of ways
you're
the you're the aggressive the aggressive
oneness is more likely to come from you
it's just saying between the two of us
but i know how to cut loose too man well
that's for sure yeah
i know how to let it go that's why
i i let go so aggressively i just like
with a i i let go with reckless abandon
that is how i would describe it
aggressively letting go but then it's
like it's just
like
yeah like the i don't know how this good
mythical evening is gonna go i don't
mean to keep bringing it up but it's
we're on the precipice of it
like the last one yeah it was just like
a big
release of one like letting go of
oneness and just like
just being just
just letting loose well the people
around you have to take cover it's cruel
it's a little bit like a tornado
you know yeah i'm i'm i'm trying to
learn that
so i'm getting better
uh
but yeah it's nice to just totally check
out of oneness
i love that and there was a hot tub and
there was a hot tub which allowed
uh let's do that and then we'll get into
the specifics um
over on the mythical society we've been
we've been doing um
these games what what have we been
calling it
the society showdown society showdown
it's we've had team rep versus team link
you can go on the mythical society and
watch the previous iterations we played
an epic game of nasty food jenga then we
played our new uh party game that you
can get at walmart or walmart.com called
we're still good
we played that had a lot of fun and then
but the the first of all you've won
you're up by three i'm winning
um
but we have a live
ultimate society showdown we're gonna
determine the the final champion between
team rhett and team link i don't even
know what we're what we're doing a
series of live
competitions davin is dreaming this
stuff up he's our game master yeah he
was on wheel of fortune uh and so you
got to be a third degree member in order
to watch the live finale only on the
mythical society join third degree to
watch this live finale if you're
listening to this after the fact
well it's archived you can go back and
experience um the live streams that we
do on the mythical society anytime you
want also don't forget
third degree quarterly or annual members
get the gmm woven blanket collectible
mythicalsociety.com um so i think
you want to talk about rafting yeah so
we both had our our site set on we all
did
rafting was you know if you think about
a central sort of the center of gravity
of this the expectations around this
trip was around this adventure that we
were going to go on rafting and it was
like oh yeah it's colorado like
you know
it's gonna be super intense and it's
gonna be well i wanted to find one that
was
i said adventurous not boring i want
class four i want class five we've done
the upper gauley in west virginia which
has
i believe class fives it was very
intense
doesn't it go to class yeah let's just
say yeah i think at certain times the
upper golly will go to class six so in
idaho springs uh the clear creek runs
through there like right next
right next to the
the freeway or whatever they call it um
it's beautiful beautiful big creek
and so a lot of white water rafting on
that and so we did the upper clear creek
and they said it was like a half day
trip
um and we get there we you know there's
like six six rafts going out we're in
we're in a raft all our own we got
pictures to prove it
and um
[Music]
there were class fours and then
a couple of what they called class fives
at the end no
they were they were only class fours we
did not go above a class four okay i
think dependent it is so dependent on
the water levels and by the time that we
were there the water levels were
starting to get low basically the end of
the season for this particular thing
shout out to amber our guide who is a
mythical beast and
uh as we were settling in and getting
our equipment uh she came up to us and
said pick me
to be your guide
she said i'm the best and i was like
yeah well that's what i said she said
pick me to be your guide and i said are
you any good
and she said i'm the best and then when
we got on the river she said actually i
have the least of experience of any
of anyone that you could have chosen
today
but she was but she's if she was a
mythical beast she's a mythical beast
and she was a great rafting guide um
and she can't we can't blame amber for
the nature of the water at that point we
because when we were planning this
we said we wanted the most intense rapid
that we could get our hands on we wanted
to be out there for the longest there
was
cara was sending emails to different
companies and people were sending back
they're like how in shape are these guys
like they're just like these are good
questions they were picturing like kevin
bacon from a river wild are they
experienced it's like
just tell them whatever they need to
hear like for us to do this stuff
because what i was kind of thinking
secretly the whole time
is that
we could create a situation that would
feel like a thriller movie like not not
necessarily like the river wall where it
turns out the guide is a murderer
spoiler alert right um
but more banjo player more like with a
bow and arrow i wanted there to be some
legitimate peril
somebody's got to get rescued hell yeah
man we got a podcast to make right
and you make it on the river
and uh but then they were like well
you can't really do the class fives now
because that's not really active but you
and we did all we could do
but nobody got hurt
well nobody died
sh amber said
we can
we can go for a swim we can topple this
thing over at a certain point if you
want to and i was like yes
and then tim was like i'd rather not
you know it was it was cold it was
raining
it was actually the most peril that it
was like and he played it's my birthday
card i was like seriously yeah i was
like wait can we at least take a vote
amber's like well it's his birthday
i'm not going to turn you guys over that
doesn't mean it's not going to happen
but i'm not going to do it it almost
happened but the scared us i was
um was it the beginning in the parking
lot the parking lot like trying to get
into this water and there was a
thunderstorm coming through it was just
like lightning lightning on the ridge
feeling very close i was like now i
realized that
you know by definition the river is the
lowest point in the valley so i guess
unlikely to get struck but i am the
tallest person in this boat
yeah
the lightning is going to find me
first
and you were wearing that pointy metal
hat yeah right um
but it was really cool
to like
push off into the creek and then
it's it's raining it's thundering
there's a little bit of lightning
it really gave it a sense of peril
i like that because that was the easier
part of the ride
and you know we were very responsive we
were you know
you get a
you get an
a woman barking orders in the back of a
boat and boy we just we're aiming to
please yeah we are
we in fact
we're talking about
how much we needed her to tell us
how good we were at whatever she told us
to do that was first like what the first
question i asked her
was how are we doing compared to the
average boat
this is a very mclaughlin question to
ask and she was like you're doing an
average like she said i was like whoa
whoa whoa whoa so
what do you mean she's like well there's
been a couple of times that not everyone
has responded
and i think she's talking about me i was
like well i'm in the front of the boat
you got to speak louder amber you blamed
her i blamed her i was like if you say
it loud enough i'm the redster is ready
to go
so then after that i was really
listening yeah and then she said okay
you're doing better than average and
me and tim who were both threes we both
felt good about that
yeah
um
and then you start you start going down
i mean the whole trip it said it was a
half day trip but i think they they
count a lot of those that's accounting
for everything like leaving your home
and getting back yeah so we were
actually
on the river for an hour which was a
disappointment i'm just going to be
honest it would have been a an hour is a
short amount of time to actually do
something when
you got to do something longer than it
takes to prep for it and recover from it
well not recover from it i'll take that
back so prep for it
yeah yeah
i think so
is foreplay prep
no
foreplay is sex man
okay i'm just i'm just trying to save
that for sex timber okay all right
um
so yeah and she you know because of the
rain
we were moving faster which was actually
good the water was coming up
so yeah it was i mean we almost got
dumped in the drink and at the end and
those there's a couple of class fours
there at the end and they both like have
the word beaver in the name which is
great it's like you gotta really nail
the slot of the beaver right and then
you're like really you're really diving
into it and
your side i mean i thought you were
going like you were going backwards like
you were deep like the whole boat was
like going in on you
got a pretty good action shot of that
yeah i'm not in most of these photos so
i don't really i don't i don't care
about the show we're blocked a little
bit i was in the back i got in the back
of the boat thinking it was the front
yeah
i got in the back of the boat thinking
you know what i'll let
the boys experience the front of the
boat because there'll be a point when we
switch
and then not if there's a knife an hour
when we switch then i'll be in the front
of the boat for the best part so i
selfishly deferred to make myself look
better when really i was i didn't get in
the front of the boat by choice it was
the only spot left it was like okay you
guys don't want to get in the front i'll
get in the front me and greg got in the
front i wish i would have gotten in the
front my favorite part of those photos
is greg's face
progressively
like everyone had a different sort of
like
you know
most of us were smiling i kind of had a
sort of a
like i put my i do what my dad does when
i'm getting ready
but i was still kind of enjoying myself
but greg looked
just astonished frightened
in a couple there's a couple of really
great shots we'll we're showing showing
them to you right now
he's done a lot more death defying river
action up there in washington attacking
and he's doing all kinds of stuff which
kind of brings me to the next point
which is we got a little taste of
adventure
but everybody wanted a little bit more
of a taste so the thing that we're
talking about now
is
next time potentially doing one of these
curated adventure trips where you've got
like a guide who leads you through now
there's something overnight they just
look like a two day one night at least
well they do this kind of thing in
alaska and i think alaska may be too
ambitious and too far away but maybe
there's something in the continental
united states that doesn't require too
much travel because we're all busy
where we can get somebody to kind of
lead us through so i'm not saying i'm
putting the call out there but if you're
like a mythical beast
guide yeah and i don't mean let's put
the call out and i don't mean like you
want to be a guide i'm saying that your
job you are
you are a professional adventure guide
yeah who leads people on these curated
adventure trips we want to do and it
in the united states it could be city
slicker-esque it could it could be full
cowboy it could be mules going down into
the grand canyon staying at the bottom
and coming back up it could be a big
round it could be a dude ranch i mean if
we want to go full city
then i would need to watch you know i
watched top gun
uh the original j because so i could
watch the new one i could do the same
thing for city slicker for the next
right thing so
with i was like can we do a rafting trip
down through the grand canyon grand
canyon but then we look at how big those
boats are we want something
private
or semi-private and we want it to be
rustic we don't want mixed company here
but yet we want it to be posh we want to
be taken care of we want to almost die
but live the most life we've ever lived
and we want to do it with our college
buddies and we want you to make it
happen yeah so i guess so let us know
hashtag your biscuits on twitter to
either we've never solicited point us in
the right direction so hard for
something
but listen again it could be alaska i it
needs to be in the comments you got to
be legit though it needs to be in the
u.s but you got to be legit i don't mean
like i've been camping
don't waste our time don't waste our
time don't waste our time and we won't
waste yours okay but it it needs to be
over a long weekend you do this for a
living okay just give more parameters it
needs to be over a little weekend we
flew in on friday and we flew back on a
monday that's what it needs to be and
he's like a four day weekend it needs to
be like so the saturday and the sunday
trip is the stuff so it's stuff we're
kind of limited in that way okay
so
we're counting on you
mythical beast and in uh connected
places
somebody's got it i mean this is a thing
that people do if we don't start cashing
in on our fame now yeah we got to do
something
what are we going to do right i'm just a
common man i drive a common van
my dog don't have a pedigree who sings
that john connelly
who's that he's a country singer from
like the 80s
well i guess i don't know him if i had
my way i'm gonna stay that way
other highlights for me
we can't be common anymore right um you
gotta live it up
i really first of all i did enjoy that
dinner we had and we were in our our
waitress was a mythical beast
emily and uh
that was a situation where we came in
the restaurant to celebrate tim's
birthday and emily was a mythical beast
and said
follow me i'll i'll be your server
and uh pick me it was an incredible
she not only was she an incredible uh
waiter but she also
told us that we should go hang out in
golden and we made the mistake of not
planning anything our second day i just
thought we were going to lounge at the
house and just look at each other and
say wow i'm so good to see you
but it turns out everybody wanted we
wanted to do more the taste of adventure
golden colorado um you can take a tour
of the
coors brewing facility but you got to
make a reservation like six months in
advance and
it can't be worth it right i mean i mean
at the end of the day it's coors you
know what i'm saying like clear no
matter how how awesome this is at the
end of the day it's a course i'm sorry
i like it for what it is but i didn't
reserve anything right and i don't and i
won't right clear creek
runs through golden
and
there's tubing that happens like there's
like i mean this is like a bustling
little town it's like a cute nice little
town and
people can rent tubes or bring your own
tube and you can either take a shuttle
or you can walk along the creek
through the middle of town and just put
in like a few miles up and pee and
there's like it's rapids
and
there were still a few people with
beverages in their hands when they were
going down but at a few points it's like
your beverage is going to be spilt
but then what goes into this a lot of
people and then it goes straight into
the coors plant the water was not
we didn't we didn't uh do the tubing we
thought about it but we we were like we
got on clothes
to like hang out here for the rest of
the day we don't want to smell like the
creek and then trying to hang out
at a beer joint so so we did what we did
in aspen which has become a tradition
now you rent electric bikes and you ride
it along the river the boys didn't know
about this like we had it was it felt
like a silver bullet like a revelation
you know when we're like we're gonna
we're gonna ride e-bikes because once
you know that there's a body of water
running through a
um a an outdoorsy town and a path next
to it yeah especially with people tubing
it's like you know there's gonna be
e-bikes we found them we did like a
e-bikes are freaking fun
they are more fun i think
than scooters
because
you can go further especially in this
instance like
on on our tours we would always do
scooters in whatever town we were in
and
so like for city navigation it's fun
yeah but when you're in like a rustic
town with like a river or a stream you
want to cover more ground
and i think the e-bike is the way to go
it's a nice
fun high-speed
tour it was definitely a highlight we
saw
a freaking
was it a mountain goat it's a bighorn
sheep big horn we saw a big horn sheep
just sitting up there on the rim that's
kind of uncommon we got to the end of
the path
and by the by this time we're like in a
canyon and we're on the outside of town
it's beautiful like the way that they've
laid this place out like the the hiking
paths and like the biking paths it's
just like they've done great planning
and we had to turn around and i just
happened to look up
and against silhouetted against the
the ridgeline who's this bighorn sheep
just he was kind of leaning over like
but you got the perfect outline
middle-aged
boys from college
it definitely had a nature like if we
had anything other than our phones we
could have gotten some i think we got
just a couple of pictures that we're now
showing you we wouldn't have seen him if
he wasn't silhouetted on the on the
right i think that was pretty uncommon
it's uncommon to see those things that
close into town i've never seen one i've
never seen one what i have now elk are
very common there you guys were flipping
out yep i saw an elk and i was like well
that's uncommon and then i saw like
seven more elk on the way to yeah
uh the house
uh one of the things that i i recommend
golden i recommend tubing they got an rv
park right there by the thing and like
if you got young kids and you just want
to take them tubing it's like it seems
like a really cool spot to just hang out
one of the things that i noticed and now
having been to colorado
two times in a short period of time
the
the apparel
yeah so there yeah there is a colorado
style and again i've been there
i wouldn't call it stop so it doesn't
matter how rich you are
you wear you look like you could do the
following things and you would be ready
for it
eat a croissant have a coffee
maybe take a phone call
hike a very long ways
ride a bike
ride on the back of a big horn sheep
like you can do all those things with
what you're wearing take it in the woods
it's like tight
athleisure wear athleisure wear yeah and
it is a thing and they all wear it and
it's not i mean i mean some of the
ladies you know i i i it
i would say that it's working for them
in my opinion um
but it isn't necessarily fashion forward
if you know what i mean yeah it's not
it yeah i didn't see it wasn't a lot of
that like hipster athleisure like i'm
going camping but i dropped thousands of
dollars to look right to do it
it's a lot more practical it's like this
clothing will dry very quickly
yeah and it's and it's aerodynamic and
it doesn't really draw attention to
itself like everything you know muted
colors blacks you know if you go down to
hollywood or
beverly hills or any cool spot
silver like anywhere you know people
wearing stuff to express themselves to
draw attention to themselves yeah you
can't really express yourself with this
stuff everybody's just really trying to
optimize
their
performance it could i mean listen let's
be honest it might be the future of
clothing because it is i like expressing
myself it is the most like star trek
clothing of any clothing
i i didn't think of it that way but i
yeah if you see futuristic clothing in a
movie it's usually form-fitting tight
looks like it would dry very quickly
it's breathable mm-hmm
repel bullets yeah it can rain maybe i
maybe they're they understand something
that we don't
because we definitely don't get like a
nice hatch we look like dudes from
l.a who are in colorado
with three guys
from other places yeah no offense guys
we're not the same greg i'll come back
to that greg has a little bit of uh
athleisure athleisure wear like some
high tech he he had he actually had uh
shoes for rafting
yeah
yeah because he has another friend named
rhett
yeah
that we all should drags him somewhere
to do stuff
everyone should have a
a friend named rhett to drag him places
right and get
i gotta buy special shoes for this
a highlight for me was watching the home
videos you know when i digitized the
stuff that went on the mythical society
it was like
the never before seen stuff we're
putting over there
i also dug up these home video like we
had the video camera around our
apartment and you know it was me you and
greg and then the next year tim moved in
and we would just pick that thing up and
film us we weren't making videos well
actually sometimes we were making video
like
comedy sketches
just for ourselves that no one would
ever see but usually it was just like we
would turn it on point it at somebody
and they would just start
dancing
or
you'd point it like somebody was on the
toilet and then you
you walk in there and film them a lot of
people sitting on toilets a couple of
times guys in showers
um and a lot of dancing
with you might need to explain yourself
a little bit here people might get the
wrong idea link
i
uh
get whatever idea you want i mean i
don't know why we did it but we did we
just
it was slice of life man it felt so
freeing felt freeing you know but it was
so fun to like sit down and watch i mean
we probably watched an hour of footage
more than that
and
i'd say we watched two hours and then
i don't know if it was related to that
or the night before
but
it just occurred to me when we were
sitting around talking one night and i
was like you know what
it's it's it's a special thing that we
have like being like
we have this bond that we formed
in our college years where you're like
you're forming who you are
and i mean we're forming so much of our
worldview and our purpose and where we
were headed in life and what
we what we believed but that uh and of
course a lot of that stuff has changed
and then on top of that
you know uh
we're internet famous
and
so all of these questions that i think i
have in the back of my mind
i realized that i had the perfect
opportunity with this
group of guys to like
gain some data here and it really boiled
down to one question which i asked i was
like you know what we were so close then
i'm so glad that like we reconnected we
stayed connected enough over the years
to like fully reconnect and spend this
weekend together
am i different
am i a different person
than i was
back then
and
i really wanted to know i was actually
i think it more so as i said it i
realized that it was like that that
question went pretty deep from me
and uh
the immediate response was like just
like a a grinning and like people
shaking their heads like no
you're not different and it felt
so good to me like it was just like
that was my favorite moment uh having
you know having people that knew me back
then that still know me now that i trust
completely and
um
that i know will shoot straight
you know i knew it wasn't lip service
because you know you have people who
make assumptions for whatever reasons
it's like okay you're you moved to
california you changed your beliefs you
this that and the other you're not the
same person you were you let x y and z
things change you
you know um
and it's one thing to get that from your
family like from my mama it's like i
know i can tell that my mom still loves
me and she's still proud of me and she
doesn't she's not like looking at me
like what happened to you you know but
it's a different thing with friends who
are like they have every right and in
that moment they would have said i
believe
you know what
yeah you're you're different dude
but
still the same as someone you know it
was it was an unequivocal
no you're the same person
and it just
uh to use the parlance it ministered to
my soul i i i felt like i needed to hear
that are you afraid that you've changed
i guess so
you know because because we do get that
messaging from people who don't ma some
people don't have busi
saying it well that's what you were
saying what you're asking
because
all of us
without exception
have changed
in so many ways in a lot of ways right
but i think the question you were asking
is like am i essentially the same person
yeah um
which i think is actually yeah which is
that's what i ask am i a different
person to me that speaks to
the reason that there's not a um
i think we can have very fruitful
even fun conversations about
things that we disagree on
because the conversation is happening
from person to person
let me kind of explain what i mean by
that
okay
uh you know one of the things that of
course this is something that i think
about a lot is the whole premise of the
first song from the james and the shame
project about believe me like take me at
my word actually
i i yeah exactly and i had a uh and i
talked a lot about in our deconstruction
stories that like
i think what ultimately everyone is
after is just see the humanity in people
you want to you want someone to see you
for who you are and see the humanity
but when you are completely steeped in
your ideology
you put it up as a shield and that's the
thing that kind of defines who you are
and that's the thing i respect so much
about these guys right
um obviously they're coming from a
different place and they have come to
different conclusions now and i'll say
places you know they're not all in this
yeah and i'll also say that
uh it
every single one of them in their own
way has
had very deep
uh
considerations about their their
worldview and their fate this like it's
a very it's not some like oh these guys
just believe this because of where
they're from or whatever it's like
yeah they have a
thoughtful it's a thoughtful approach to
the conclusions that they have come to
we've ended up in different places for
myriad reasons but then we can come back
and we can have these conversations
where it is a human talking to another
human
whereas
so many of the interactions that you can
have with someone
of faith
and also someone who is of a faith that
you used to be of
is that it is a conversation with
a project
right it's like this person is a project
this person the person who has left the
flock is in the wrong has to be
corrected has to be brought back into or
even in relation or even loved back into
it yeah yeah yeah not you know if the if
the if sort of the premise or the the
foundation
of your relationship is one of
trying to bring them in
trying to bring them back to channel
agree with you
then that
influences the entire conversation in
the relationship and i honestly
if
these guys saw us in that way we
wouldn't be like yeah let's go hang out
and have a weekend together no because i
can't
listen i'm not no i'm not gonna be your
project and i don't want you to be my
project because i'm not trying to change
their minds about anything either so i
think that the really interesting thing
is that we can have these
conversations that are real
that are honest that are that are you
know no holds barred in a lot of ways
but also it's just like there's no
offense and there's no dif there's no
defense there's no defensiveness yeah
because we're connecting on a personal
level
and
and we all that's all you can ask of
somebody because we've all
well i would say you and i
have definitely
and probably the other guys too i know
that we
all in our college experience have had
moments of like
making
people into projects like trying to
trying to persuade or change people's
minds and that that is like
the main
through line of the relationship
it's like
this carrot that's dangling out there
this ulterior motive beyond just
being friends
you know that's that's
that's a complication
um or a potential side effect of having
evangelistic mindset right
is that that's the main
motive of a friendship yeah and
ironically it's something that we were
trying to address from the inside out
when we worked in campus crusade at at
times and also with like things that we
were developing
in terms of things that we talked about
but
i guess my point is
we we've all been on that side of it so
like we're v i think we're we're very
sensitive to it like you know when it's
happening because we used to do it
yeah right yeah so now
it's like a magician suddenly doing
tricks in a group of magicians
yeah we all oh you're doing we all kind
of know we're doing the thing that we
all know how to do that would never work
and i don't you know
over the pandemic having all those video
calls and the conversation we would talk
about all the spiritual stuff but then
we would also move on and then at times
there'd be like pointed questions
but the point of questions would never
be from a pers
a point of persuasion they would be from
a point of curiosity and care yeah so
and you
because we could sniff out anything else
any of us could so i think that laid a
groundwork for uh us to have such a
great weekend and for us to have great
active
relationships now
um i think another piece of it even so
totally remove this this the spiritual
journey part of it
there's something
i mean it's just special to have these
college friends like
i've heard of people who've had this
like even my my aunt tc like she's got
her group of i think it's high school
friends who's they still get together
and hang out like every year or so
you know
it's really cool you see those things
happening
uh you hear about oh i'm getting
together with my girls and my boys
from from way back when um
there's something special with that type
of friendship that if it's lasted that
long
and then
there was just an ease to it like it was
not
complicated what we've had
we've made friends
really close friends that then
things have fizzled out or things change
you know you go through friends
yeah
over time
and
like i really value the friends i have
now and we could have a great time going
on a trip and i think that there's
complete trust and
but it's something different
about
and
even in like the most vibrant of
friendships and i think it's because we
lost friends maybe that's what's behind
this for me
we lost close friends
you know over the past six years or
whatever that
there's something a little bit it plants
something that's a little bit tenuous oh
there's a tenuous nature like this may
not last forever as good as this is it
may not last forever but then i feel
like that's totally gone with this group
of guys because
it's been so long and it's it's just
about and it was so
uncomplicated for us to hang out that
weekend
that that there's zero question in my
mind
that
it's going to be something we want to do
again and
because it's not loaded and there's no
question marks i think it's just
i think a lot of it has to do with
friendships that are formed in those
really pivotal moments in your life and
and you know college is one of them
right i i always talk about it and i and
you know i know that
things have changed so much just as a
society and as a country and college is
so hard to afford and like you can't so
many people can't have that experience
but essentially whatever is happening to
you between the ages of 18 to 21 to 22
is so significant
that whoever you are in close
friendships with at that point
uh
there's a great chance
that you're gonna you know the good the
good ones you're gonna stay in touch
with and you're gonna be able to step
back into that because you all changed
together in a really
accelerated way that you'll never change
again for the rest of your life as much
as you change during that time yeah i i
just
i wish that for my kids i see that
lily's got a group of friends actually
high school friends that like she's
still yeah getting together
it's coming to happen um
so
that makes me so happy that like i think
this is a good group of people
they're good people you know they're not
they're not a wreck there's not drama
you know it's like it's hard it's hard
to not have drama that's the thing you
learn with
like you get teenagers and their
friendships good god i mean not even i
mean pre-teens
so much
more so much drama
yeah you know and if you can if you can
find a place where there's little to no
drama and you can build connection
i mean it could it could last for
22 years
and and and counting in our case
and i it you know it's a cliche
in fact even my mom
said this on the phone when i talked to
her the other day she was like
and i bet you all picked up right where
you left off and then that is
that's how some of those friendships are
my mom
uh gets together with her college
roommates every year every year since
college has gotten together with them
really like i think there's like four or
five of them that were like suite mates
or or whatever but what do they go to a
water park uh it depends on you know the
defense yeah mostly water parks
um
uh of course the pandemic
put a wrench in that but so i don't know
the last time that they did it but you
know that is yeah she understood like i
mean she saw us together in some of the
pictures on facebook yeah and she's like
you know i know exactly what that's like
to get together with
you know your old friends in that way
and you you basically
like you know like with her
there was a nickname
her her
maiden name was cowan and somebody had
mispronounced it they call her like
callan i think and so they're just like
that's what her name is with them right
she's got like her own name with them
and that's cute and so you just kind of
like you return to this place of like
before
life
got
complicated
you know yeah and so you kind of step
back into that and also it helps when
you know we're all basically
dealing with i mean we're in different
same stage of life but same stage of
life like we've all been married 20
years
yeah
we've all got children
multiple multiple children
yeah um
and so it's just like you those things
right there you immediately have a whole
bunch of stuff to talk about
uh
in terms of life stage in a way that we
don't often
doesn't often happen i mean some of our
closest friends here in la are you know
similar life stays been married the same
amount of time
uh kids of us of a similar age but
that's kind of uncommon enough first of
all it's uncommon in l.a to meet
somebody outraged who's been married for
20 years
like that does we always surprise people
only 21 years now
um
and also somebody our age who has kids
our age
yeah
you know you kind of have to go back to
people who came from where you came from
and we're on the same track
graduate high school graduate college
get married have children that's the
track
and there's not a lot of people out here
who are on that track so
it's it's cool to to connect with people
who kind of made all those same types of
decisions
it was a success it was uh it was
life-giving
especially because no one died
uh on a boat
uh but if somebody had almost died it
would have been so good this podcast
would have been that much more
entertaining and that's why
we're gonna say again
is this your wreck if you're a
legitimate guide out there oh who can
make us feel like we're gonna die okay i
don't actually want to
i want to feel like i might
could die but i'd also like
an like a nice nice meal the good
dinners would be great and then um
you know it i
i guess i i i'd like a mattress honestly
i need like an air air mattress
situation yeah i need you know i don't
do well if i'm sleeping on the ground
and hammocks i can't really get
comfortable in those so we play hard
sleep great yeah yeah yeah we're looking
for like a glamping situation play hard
eat hard sleep
perceived peril during the day
right perceived peril
like if you're gonna be a grizzly bear
it's trained you know what i mean yeah
and in a cage
uh you know who you are okay hashtag air
biscuits uh i've got two wrecks
the first wreck is i want to remind you
about good mythical evening because it's
going to be a good time
goodmythicalevening.com get your tickets
it's live exclusively on moment house
second wreck is your tickets uh as is
not uncommon on this podcast we will
talk about something that people were
talking about uh months ago that we
discovered because we're middle-aged
dads
uh but you may also be a person who
didn't watch this the first time around
and that is that nick cage movie the
unbearable weight of massive talent i
think is the name of it the one with
pedro pascal yeah
it was a delight well there's a delight
i'll have to see it
yeah i would say that and then city
slickers okay can you do a double
double matinee
and as always if you want to let us know
a response a correction a question
any type of
interaction you can call us and leave a
voicemail
one eight eight eight earpods
[Music]
i'll catch you next week what's up rhett
and link um don't know if you guys want
to hear me say this but my dad is a
southern man born and reared in texas
and he in fact spent many mornings in
his tidy whities in front of his family
of sick when i was younger since my
family or all immigrants from austria
it's like austrian culture for everyone
in the house to always like be naked
unless you're gonna go out for my whole
childhood i was running around naked
with my siblings with my mom my dad
everyone was just naked in the house all
the time once i started going through
puberty i realized how weird that was
and i was like nope never doing that
again and so now i'm the only one in my
household who's not naked hey rhett and
link this is katie um i was just
listening to your episode about red's
terrible vacation i wanted to emphasize
i also just got back from north carolina
on a beach trip with my family and after
the first two days i got covered too and
i had to stay inside
the entire time away from my family and
not on the beach so rat you're not the
only one who had a terrible vacation
this summer in north carolina i written
link my name is elise i live in ohio and
i am absolutely obsessed with whales so
red story about whale watching being on
an ear biscuit was the absolute best
crossover of my life thanks for talking
about my obsession bye hey in case you
missed it we launched a new collection
over at
psyc.la everything we release over there
all the products and apparel change
right before your eyes so check it out
and we're giving you a discount code to
use on your first visit shop psyc.la
drop in eb made you look at check out
and enjoy 10 off your whole purchase eb
made you look
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]